this is a hobbit valley now you can't be
seen in it
that was the Lauer behind every
memorable character is a meticulously
chosen wardrobe whether the costume is
extremely flashy or completely blends in
costume design provides an amazing
opportunity to give us insight into a
character and the world around them
because just like in the real world what
you wear says a lot about you I'm always
said there's an awful lot you can tell
about a person by their shoes I want to
take a look at costume design as a tool
for filmmakers to tell their story in
many of cinema's most important movies
costume designers are the secret heroes
the people who are merciless with in a
world seamlessly and effectively without
getting nearly the same recognition as
actors or directors so let's get
sketching to push too hard dialing back
the word costume invariably gets
associated with Halloween dress up and
pretending to be somebody else and
sometimes that's the function of
clothing in a movie usually live in
cologne clothes but the majority of
costume design operates on completely
opposite principles their goal is to
create authentic and realistic people on
the screen not actors playing dress-up
oh it's not a costume I mean no costume
design is an added layer towards the
immersive magic of film period clothing
is meant to place you in the time period
of the movie Gone with the Wind is
famous for its engaging costume design
while there is some 1930s Flair in the
hair style the clothes still managed to
immerse the audience in the Civil War
era and accurately reflect Scarlett's
fall from grace the way she designs her
own clothing also serves as a nice
metaphor for the need to literally and
figuratively reconstruct herself after
the war at its best costume design is a
vital layer of world building and it
works well in totally foreign places
when people talk about the original Star
Wars they usually praise the plot
characters or special effects but the
costume design was also fantastic it
combines what we're used to seeing with
the completely alien princess Leia's
costume design is right in the middle of
looking like she's from a foreign planet
and looking like royalty as we
understand it in all the designs the
robots generals and soldiers their
wardrobe is alien enough to transport us
to an exciting and different world but
familiar enough to keep us grounded and
what we already understand our mersive
costuming is more difficult than you may
think
Edith had the winner of eight Oscars for
costume design and the inspiration for
Edna mode designed for many movies
taking place in present day so she just
dressed her characters in the style of
her
problem is by the time the movie was
shot edited and released the style would
change and the dresses became tacky so
she had to anticipate the future and
make something look modern but not tied
down to a specific trend and she was one
of the first to address this issue that
still shows up today striking the
balance between looking too dated or too
generic so a movie made in the 70s might
have generic costuming but a movie about
the 70s embraces the old-school style to
bring about the nostalgia of a lost time
it's why eight-mile looks like it could
have taken place at any time but
wrappers look ridiculous in their music
videos that came out the same year
fashion is not the primary thing the
primary effort in motion pictures is to
tell a story the plain hoodie works as a
blank slate emphasizing Eminem's quest
to succeed purely on talent and nothing
flashy while also focusing attention on
his face
either way costuming is supposed to
compliment the style of your film
whether you're going for realism or
something more flashy along with
immersion many costume choices are to
make characters stand out of their
worlds Willy Wonka's introduction takes
place over 30 minutes into the movie and
the praise always goes to Gene Wilder's
amazing performance but it's also an
example of great costume design while
all the other characters dressed in
clothing stylized from the late 1800s or
as Cowboys and other caricatures Wonka's
wardrobe is a hybrid of the Victorian
jacket tail and buttoning of the 19th
century but the collar and color scheme
all embody the style of the 1970s so we
get a character who visually stands out
as both out of his world and ahead of
his time the costuming in the remake
emphasizes the out-of-this-world part
but it has no grip in reality so it
makes him seem more like a cartoon
caricature than an out-of-touch
visionary bonnie-and-clyde takes place
in the 1930s but their style wardrobe
and obsession with the media put them
right into the 1960 it helps make them
appear anti-establishment much like the
young people in the real world during
the making of this film in 1967
Michael Corleone wears his military
uniform to stand out amongst the classy
gangster suits but as he gets sucked
into the life his clothing makes the
appropriate transition for gangsters
wardrobe indicates a transition into the
Mafia this example of costume design
actually does play into the initial
concept of wearing a costume the
gangster gets new attire to try to fit
into high society but no matter what
they stand out as gangsters in many
movies you can tell they aren't really
high society they're just playing
dress-up
my shoes I think right my gangster like
other gangsters Walter White place dress
up to help him feel like a gangster but
eventually he becomes the gangster he
was only imitating before costumes give
us insight into the character wearing it
Luke Skywalker's wardrobe has the visual
aesthetic of martial arts gear implying
he's undergoing training obi-wan Kenobi
is dressed like a monk because he's
doing the teaching in the force awakens
the role to have reversed and so have
the costume choices new teachers new
student the shoes in the opening of
strangers on a train
tell us which character is more well-off
and which character is more of an
everyman it may just be me but the black
and white shoes look somewhat menacing
they really stand out in the frame by
being so bright and flashy Tyler Durden
is costume design and Fight Club always
contrasts the color palette of the
setting and other characters almost like
he isn't supposed to be there in the
first place along with actor personality
and direction color scheme and costume
design is an impressive and effective
way to make a character stand out or
blend in in 500 days of summer the
opening title sequence establishes the
Wardrobe color for the two characters
brown for Tom and blue for summer
throughout the movie the coloring ships
around them when summer enters Tom's
world the setting is colored brown while
summer's world is blue the dance
sequence has all the actors dressed in
blue to represent Tom thinking about
summer costume coloring gives us mental
cues as to how the story is progressing
and by the end of the movie we realize
their colors don't mix and they part
ways movies become classics when all the
production elements come together to
make something great and that includes
costuming so when you look back at your
favorite characters think about what
they're wearing and of course remember
the most important rule of costume
design okay
thanks for watching here it is the cool
slightly trans fall just a bit of a
break from the norm just a little
problem the breaks of a night meat of
all that